>>Daniel Sandler: Hi, everybody.
My name is Dan Sandler.
I'm here to talk a little bit about Daydream.
Oh, I recovered that slide so we're ahead
of time.
Good.
I'm on the system UI team, which is part of
the Android platform team, which is what exactly
is -- it's typically made up of two pieces
underneath the hood -- and if you haven't
built your own RAM because you don't live
in a cabin in the woods, you may not be familiar
with these.
One of them is the launcher -- you've probably
seen that -- and the other one is everything
else.
So system UI covers basically the launcher
plus all the other pixels on the display that
don't belong to the app, notifications, navigation,
gestures.
I see we have an obsolete screen shot here.
I'll put that away.
And in Android 4.2 we brought in something
called Daydream as part of the system UI.
It's a screen saver essentially.
So why did we bring this in Android?
To understand where this future comes from
you have to go back -- set the way-back machine
to 2009 and the Motorola Droid or Milestone
depending on your locale.
A great little device, built like a tank.
I remember when I thought this was a huge
phone.
And this was -- we're really excited to launch
this with a number of really cool accessories.
It was the first time we had done this with
a Google-involved Android phone.
We had the desk dock or the multimedia station.
We had the car dock.
We did not ship that one.
[ Laughter ]
>>Daniel Sandler: But what all these have
in common is that they invoked a dock mode
in the platform which is new to Eclair.
And what happens in dock mode is you launch
dock apps.
What is dock apps?
Well, in case you haven't seen it, here is
a screen shot of the beautiful Eclair dock
experience which was built into the desktop
application in Android 2.
And it's got all kinds of great features.
Look at all this stuff.
It's got your next alarm.
It shows the date.
You can see your wallpaper through it.
It shows the battery right underneath the
real battery.
You can switch it to night mode so it doesn't
blind you or the person next to you while
you're sleeping.
It shows the weather and then it has all this
other stuff, these crazy little buttons at
the bottom.
So you can go to the alarm because you need
to change your alarm.
There was a slide show button that did something
weird in gallery.
There was a music button that did something
else.
And what is this doing here?
Why do we have another home key again not
so far from the main home key?
Well, we decided that if your phone was in
a dock that the most important button on the
device should take you back to that dock app
experience so it's really convenient too,
but then you needed a way to actually get
home so we added this whole rigmarole.
What a mess.
And I should mention we discovered when we
were building this that if you show this great
glanceable information on a dock for hours
at a time, say while you're sleeping or while
you're at work, it can actually burn into
the LCD or the OTA screen.
How very 1990s, right?
So we had to implement a screen saver into
the dock application, and every other dock
application would have to do the same thing.
We toned it down a little bit in Honeycomb
and ICS, but dock apps has basically been
the same since then.
Most of the code inside it is not dedicated
to showing the time.
It's not all that hard.
Most of the code in there is to give you a
way to get back to the launcher, to handle
the screen saver timeout, to track the power
status of the device.
There's a whole bunch of fussy way clock things
you have to do to be a well-behaved dock application,
but the basic idea was kind of interesting.
Dock apps are like bow ties.
They're cool.
You have this customized user experience for
a particular situation.
I've set my device in this little box that
is going to make it do something different.
It's very easy for me to just drop it into
that dock and get a cool experience, full
of this glanceable, sort of ambient information
that is otherwise not appropriate to show
on your device because you want to save power
and it's not plugged in, so you turn the screen
off.
But dock apps were pretty annoying, too.
We had to do this whole home key capture thing.
We got a bunch of feedback from users that
it was confusing, that they couldn't go home
when the device was in a dock or that they
had to figure out and learn whether to actually
support that.
And it required you to shell out 50 bucks
for a special piece of hardware just to have
the privilege of being able to use this dock
application.
Or like my friend Jeff in the Cambridge office,
you can build your own.
This would be back to the cabin in the woods
department.
It had some nice features.
He put in an NFC button so it would launch
his favorite application when he put his Nexus
S in there.
It sunk into the charger at the bottom, went
with any decor.
It was very nice.
But the developer experience for this was
awful, too.
Not just confusing for users, but as a developer
now you have decide, okay, am I going to take
over the home key or not?
And if I do -- if you don't take over the
home key there's no way for the user to get
back to your application so you've got to
do an ongoing notification, which is gross
for other reasons.
By the way, I'm also the notifications guy,
so I don't like those ongoings.
And then if you do decide to take over the
home key then now you need to allocate space
in the UI for a launcher button, which if
you're trying to create a delightful experience,
it is not the first thing you want to do.
So as a developer you have to deal with the
whole issue of way clocks.
If you put your device in the dock, it goes
on the charger and if you want a nice dock
app it's got to keep the screen on.
So you've got to hold a way clock, but now
you have to watch and see if the device is
removed from the dock and remove the way clock
and all this kind of stuff.
And then you have to deal with the whole screen
saver thing so you have to implement your
own idle timer, which means you have to duplicate
the idle time and functionality in the system.
It's a mess.
We wanted to do something better for developers.
We wanted to do something better for users.
That's where Daydream comes from.
We kind of introduced it quietly along with
Android 4.2 last fall.
There was a blog post about it later -- late
in the winter to sort of describe it.
We haven't really talked a lot about it, but
that's what I'm here to do today.
Features of the Daydream -- the Daydream API
is they should be really easy for developers
to write.
It should be a fun afternoon project for you
to sit down, take existing pieces of your
apps UI or build something completely from
scratch and have something running quickly.
They need to be launched automatically for
the user just like dock apps did so it's easy
to get into this feature.
We want to offer the full API available to
Android applications.
Any way you want to draw, any way you want
to interact with the users, Daydreams should
allow you to do it.
And we wanted to give you a whole bunch of
other stuff from the platform to make writing
this whole thing a lot simpler.
So Daydream is a feature that the user will
encounter when?
Well, while docked.
If the user drops the device into one of these
things, Daydream will start automatically
if this little button is ticked.
The second option allows you to Daydream more
like a screen saver, so any time it's plugged
into something that will charge it, your device
will idle out.
Instead of into a screen that is off, it will
idle out into Daydream.
So Daydream basically replaces the screen
off when the device is charging if you have
that second button ticked.
And the third radio button will allow you
to cover both cases.
The default for Android 4.2 is just while
docked so that people aren't surprised by
this new behavior, but this is where you would
go to inside settings and display to change
the way that Daydream starts up.
Daydream will not, however, automatically
start if something is holding a wake lock.
So if something else, some other app is keeping
the screen on, Daydream isn't going to automatically
turn on after an idle timeout, which I told
you Daydream is supposed to replace screen
off so this sort of works.
This follows those rules.
It also works really well because apps that
hold the screen on like that are sending us
a really strong signal.
They do not want to be obscured.
The user is looking at this.
Even though the user is not touching it, the
user is not tickling that idle timeout, the
app should continue to be visible by the user.
So video playback is the canonical example.
Other dock or kiosk apps sort of bespoke experiences
where the user might not be interacting with
it for awhile, but it needs to keep that screen
on and not obscured.
Again, they hold a way clock, Daydream won't
trigger.
Finally games.
Most games are interacting with, so it's not
a problem, but if there were some kind of
game where you were going to stare at it for
a very long time -- maybe it's an eye-tracking
game, I don't know -- if you hold a way clock,
Daydream isn't going to start on top of it.
So I said that Daydream should be easy to
write.
This is essentially the core of the implementation
here.
Step 1, extend DreamService and Step 2, go
nuts.
Do whatever you want.
We'll get back to lots more code examples
in a little bit, but right now I want to draw
your attention to we've got a method on dreaming
started and we want to override and set a
content view just like we were in activity
and then whatever you want to do, you're free
to do that until the Daydream ends.
So you might ask okay, if this is so much
like an activity why not make an activity?
Why make it a service?
We tried it internally or we thought internally
to build the whole Daydream infrastructure
just based on plain old activities.
It didn't work so well in practice.
There was a bunch of bookkeeping that you
had to do just like a dock app.
So we weren't saving the developer a whole
lot of work.
Card manager had a hard time keeping track
of this so it could be automatically started
and stopped when you docked and undocked the
device, things like that.
And the most important thing is that you were
running in the wrong window layer.
If you imagine Android, there's the wallpaper
and there's a bunch of applications and a
bunch of systems stuff like the status bar
and dialogue boxes.
Those activities are running in the middle.
So if a dialogue box comes up it's just going
to sit there on top of an activity indefinitely.
So if you have a great screen safer and an
OTA dialogue comes up, that's going to be
burned into the device by the next morning,
so that's not going to work.
Getting back to the features of Daydream,
I said that once you had set up your content
view and triggered on dreaming started you
can basically do whatever you want, and that
includes this entire suite of layouts, widgets,
however you want to interact with the user.
Like I said, it's basically the entire Android
UI toolkit is available to you in a Daydream.
And I want you to take a look at the way this
contrasts with the other things that we've
allowed you to do as sort of these kind of
customization tools.
So app widgets, for example.
If you implement a widget for the launcher
it's the same kind of glanceable information,
right?
It's there kind of when the user happens to
be looking at the device, maybe is about to
do something else.
You can show the weather, time, what have
you, but you really only get those top two
bullet points and even then it's a little
weak.
You get some of the standard layouts, you
get some of the widgets, only those that have
specially been marked to be viewed as remote
views.
You don't get the full UI toolkit and you
really don't get the full suite of touch interaction
either.
You get clicks, that's about it, because everything
else is reserved for the app widget host,
the launcher, the thing that needs to be able
to move widgets around.
So that's not all that rich and exciting.
We also have live wallpapers.
We have live wallpapers that let you do kind
of whatever kind of drawing you want to the
canvas of the surface that you're handed,
but you don't have access to the rest of the
UI toolkit.
You can't use views to lay things out.
You can't interact with the user.
You sort of get touches, but if you've written
a lot of wallpaper you know it's not all that
satisfying.
And you certainly can't do this other stuff
like view animation or video playback.
So Daydream lets you do all this.
Daydream has access to the complete UI toolkit
so you can build really kind of whatever you
want.
There are some other freebies.
I told you you get free stuff from the platform
when you implement a Daydream.
You are automatically started and stopped.
You don't have to worry about that.
You don't have to worry about tracking user's
idle time.
You don't have to worry about dock events.
That's all handled for you.
You just look for the dreaming started and
stopped life cycle events.
I mentioned you have access to the user's
touch and interaction and so forth and the
keyboard, too.
If you choose to be non-interactive, if you
just want to make flying kitchen appliances,
if that's your thing and you want it to dismiss
as soon as you touch the screen, that's really
easy.
You say set interactive false and again Daydream
takes care of the rest for you.
And finally, you get that crucial special
window on top of the device.
I know, I know, there's that other way to
get windows on top of the device.
That's gross.
Don't do that, do this instead, please.
But I still haven't gotten to the why.
Why do you actually want to go and implement
this in your app?
Okay, it's fun and easy, but why should I
take the time?
I'm busy.
I'm an Android developer.
I read Reddit.
I don't have time for this kind of thing.
So I argue that this is a chance for your
app to be free, to finally be free of all
of its features, all of its use cases, all
of its menus and its settings, free to be
experimental, free to be weird, free to delight
the user.
In a Daydream you don't need action bars,
you don't need settings, you don't need fragments.
You don't need all that serious business stuff
in your application.
This is an opportunity for you to make the
art exhibit version of your app.
It's fun.
So okay.
This is a developer conference.
Where is the code?
Here it comes.
Get ready.
The first one we're going to do, we're going
to build a very simple Daydream.
And let me show this to you on the Nexus 7
over here.
I'm going to switch and see if I can do this.
Apparently the answer is no.
There we go.
So this is not the one I wanted to show you.
So this is the first Daydream that we're going
to build here.
It's really, really simple.
It moves something around the screen.
I know we talked about this as being very
1990s.
This is very 1980s, but it's an important
building block.
Any time you build something even more sophisticated,
you probably are going to have some arrow
state or some message that you need to move
around the screen.
You can just pull this code directly in.
So back over here on the slides, the implementation
starts like this: This jumper class, I'm going
to extend frame layout.
You could do some other view group or whatever.
I like frame layout.
It's easy, it's pretty simple, and allows
you to put other stuff inside of it.
So jumper is going to be a class, it's a subclass
of frame layout that moves itself around inside
of its parent, and whatever you want to put
inside of it, like a picture of Dianne's cat
or an error message or fortune cookie or whatever,
it doesn't care.
Here is a runnable.
Basically what's happening here is it's looking
at the bounds of its parents, looking at its
own bounds, picking a new random spot and
then doing it again in two seconds.
This is very simple view kind of stuff.
And then when it's attached to window it's
going to fire off that runnable for the first
time.
So as soon as you put this view into a window
it will start bouncing around.
It's important to note -- on the next slide.
On this slide I'll show you the XML for this
is really simple.
The frame layout for the whole screen is on
the outside and the jumper is in the middle
and it will move itself around.
So what is important to note is that there
is really nothing Daydream specific so far.
This is like straight up view programming.
If you went to implementing your own custom
views earlier today you saw even more sophisticated
examples than this.
This is pretty straight ahead.
Where is the Daydream aspect of this?
Here's DreamService again.
I showed you a little snippet of code earlier
that looked like this.
Ondreaming started.
I'm going to set content view to that layout
that I just described and that's it.
And in fact, I mentioned the very simple activity
like life cycle of a Daydream before.
This is how it goes: Attached to window, dreaming
started, dreaming stopped, detached from window.
So you can override these things.
Most of the time all you need to do is override
ondreaming started, set up a layout and run
with it.
It's very, very easy.
The last thing you need to do is declare that
this is a Daydream, so you can see it in settings.
You do that through the Android manifest like
everything else.
Inside your application you have a service
mentioning your Daydream, and the important
bit here is the action, the intent filter.
Android service dreams DreamService.
That's how settings knows how to find you.
That's how the DreamService knows how to start
you.
Okay.
All right.
So this is boring.
Let's get a little fancier.
So remember I told you that Daydreams could
do anything, including view style animations,
right?
So we're going to go ahead and go in here,
and this is our old code.
You see it does set X, set Y.
We'll replace those with the fluent interface.
Now it's animate X, animate Y.
And hey, let's just throw in rotation just
for fun.
So let's see what that looks like, and I have
that running over here as well.
There we go.
All right.
Now, this feels high octane.
I'm excited about that.
I'm not sure Dianne's cat likes that so much.
We'll have to see.
Should we keep going and make this more interesting?
Let's see here.
I'm going to show you this third jumper example
here.
So this is the same kind of thing, just moving
itself around with a slightly different kind
of rotation pattern.
But remember that I told you that the way
we implemented this is that you drop a jumper
view into anything and it will move itself
around in its parent.
What that means is we can go and throw more
of these in.
Like you want this to be more sophisticated,
let's see if we can tempt the demo gods here.
Maybe they've had their fill.
And oh, you're not seeing this on the other
monitor.
All right.
Move.
Move our code over there.
You can't see that.
I can't see that either.
What we're going to do here is I'm going to
add some extra stuff here.
So let's see.
Wow, I really need a larger font to do this
on the monitors down there.
We're going to add some extra views here.
I'm going to copy this one, make another one,
add a whole bunch.
Doesn't matter.
Let's see here.
And then I'm going to get some more of these,
too.
So again, the nice thing about implementing
this all as basic view stuff is that anything
that works in an activity will work in a Daydream.
So we're going to go ahead and see if we can
run this.
Did I get any compilers?
No, believe it or not.
I shouldn't have tempted them.
Let's go back to the Wolf.
All right.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
Much better.
So just adding more and more views to the
parent.
Again, daydream doesn't care.
Daydream will let you do whatever you want.
We could ship this.
This is pretty good.
All right.
Let's go back, go back to the slides here.
Okay.
So, again, you can pull this source code and
maybe with less spinning and use it as the
error message in your own implementation.
So that's, you know, a couple of canned animations
in a row.
Now let's move on to continuous animations.
So often instead of doing something periodically,
you often want something moving all the time
in your daydream.
There's lots of ways to do this.
I'm going to show you one such.
And this story starts over winter break.
This is a little art project I did with my
son.
There he is dressed as a pirate.
There he is.
Awesome.
I had him sit down and draw some snow flakes
and a snowman for me because we were vacationing
in Texas where there is no snow.
We took a picture of it.
We pulled it into a bunch of sprites and then
dropped it into something very similar to
the code you've already seen.
So I'm going to go ahead and switch back over
here and show you what that looked like.
Here was his snow storm that we can enjoy
anytime.
So this was nice; right?
It turned out really well and it was really
easy to do, again, with daydream and the view
animation stuff.
I'll show you who this work right now.
So rather than implementing a view that moved
itself around in its parent, now we're going
to implement this as a layout that animates
all its children.
You can throw whatever you want into this
container and it's going to start falling
like snow flakes.
And the way we're going to do is using this
class called item animator.
Again, there are lots of other ways to do
continuous animation.
Time animator is one of my favorites because,
again, it feels like the rest of the view
animation API.
It's very easy to use.
You start it and stop it whenever you want
and then you implement this time listener
interface, and you're good to go.
So snowy day, attach to windows starts the
animator, detach from window stops the animator.
Pretty straightforward stuff.
So what happens in the animator.
But first I have to show you what happens
when you add a view.
So I told you anything you throw in here gets
turned into a snow flake.
Now, if you were doing this for real, you
might have a very sophisticated physics engine
going on here.
I didn't have that, so instead, I created
a little struct that holds some basic velocity
information and I stuffed it into the view
tags.
You see right that there, the v.set tag.
This saves me the trouble of having to create
a separate model of all the objects.
As soon as the view comes in, stick some stuff
in the view tag and we can animate it later.
Here it is.
On-time update.
This is the thing that gets called back from
time animator every time choreographer wants
an animation frame.
So basically a v-synced, buttery smooth animation
call-back loop.
So here essentially I'm going through every
single of the children, pulling the tag back
out, getting the velocities out, incrementing
the view, nudging it along in its simulation,
and then putting it back where it belongs.
There's a little bit of code here that is
taken out in the slide that allows the snow
flakes to wrap around from the bottom to the
top and the sides.
And then finally, there's always that daydream
part at the end because everything else that
we've seen before, you can put in any application.
Here's the dream service bit.
Load a bunch of snow flakes.
Set the content view.
Again, this is what you do to set up a daydream.
And then there's one last trick I'm going
to show you here, kind of unrelated to daydream
but it's a great little trick.
Remember we had all those sprites drawn as
white snow flakes on a black background.
I don't actually want those black rectangles
floating on top of each other.
I want to be able to see the snow flakes through
one another.
Are we going to work out the HDMI switcher
here?
Here we go.
How are we going to do that?
We're going to do that with an extra mode
on the paint assigned to a hardware layer.
Here's how it works.
We create the ported up extra mode screen
which will create that exact compositing appearance
that we want, and then for each one of these
views, as we add it, we give it a hardware
layer, use that paint and then put it into
the parent.
Voila, you get snow flakes.
Okay.
So what else can you do with daydream?
So the first thing is we talked a little bit
earlier about whether it's interactive or
not.
So if you decide you want the user actually
to be able to interact with the daydream,
because the default is you touch it, it goes
away.
Again, flying kitchen appliances.
If you want it to be interactive, you run
this one method call and suddenly you have
again full touch input to your daydream.
This allows you to do all kinds of great things
like the default daydream photo table that's
part of Android 4.2.
Hopefully you've seen this.
This is a great way to show off, you know,
a bunch of vacation photos, your recent Google+
photos, and so forth.
It throws them all out as if they were photographs
scattered on a table but there's this great
ability that if you see one that you want
to look at, you don't have to suffer with
it being obscured by other things.
You can move them out of the way and pull
them forward.
This is a great thing to have on a screen
savior.
It's something that can do a great thing when
you're not paying attention.
But if you're interested, you want to drill
in and pay attention to what's going on there,
you can touch and, in fact, more than one
person can be interacting with it at a time;
right?
You get the full multi-touch API of Android.
So this is a great thing to have in the API.
Something else you want to do is give that
daydream a setting.
Daydreams love settings.
This is what binds an activity to this little
settings button inside the daydream portion
of the settings app.
And the way you do that is, in your manifest
again, you add this little bit of metadata.
It's very much like metadata for live wallpaper
if you've done that, that points to an XML
file where you can point to that activity.
Not every daydream will need it, some are
just art projects, but if you have configurable
settings, if you want to make the hours bold
or not bold, if you're into that kind of thing,
this might be a great opportunity to do that.
Another pro tip for developing daydreams is
to actually use activity.
Since the API is so similar, since the life
cycle is so similar, it's very easy to share
code between a daydream and an activity that
allows you to hook it up to your IDE for testing.
So again, we'll look at the same block of
code we've seen over and over in this talk.
You should be able to write it by heart now.
There is the activity version.
So these are pretty close; right?
Dreaming started on start.
Dream service, activity.
And again, you can wire that up to run in
your favorite IDE so that it's very easy to
go straight to testing, and then debugging
and so forth.
If you factor out your code, you can keep
your activity and dream service subclasses
short and then all of the stuff related to
your animation, your experience just goes
in one place.
Another thing to do is port your live wallpaper,
if you have one.
There's no reason not to go and apply it to
the daydream API, especially if you're just
drawing into a canvas.
If you're doing fancy OpenGL stuff, it's a
little more complicated and we'll come to
that in a second.
I can quickly show you right now -- well,
that's an early implementation.
Thank you, Baron.
This is the actual implementation.
By now we have an old screen saver from BOS,
if you remember that.
It's very simple and the first implementation
was live wallpaper, because that's all we
had, but implementing it as a daydream was
really trivial.
Again, on dreaming started.
We set up everything.
And, in fact, this view you notice I just
say new view.
The view doesn't do anything.
It's not even a very special view, but all
of the logic was built into a drawable.
So the by now drawable is the background drawable
of the view, and then we have a call back
to make sure the background drawable is invalidated
every now and again.
It's really easy.
I mentioned a little bit about OpenGL.
If you want to use Open GL in a daydream,
you want to move to technical view.
If you are using GL surface view, you may
have noticed it it's pretty janky getting
that set up, particularly with window transitions.
Technically, Romain has told me the tech review
is the way to go.
Please do not argue with Romain on this.
You have to assume he's right on it.
If you go to AFP you can get the source code
to the colors daydream, which is a great example
of tech review but OpenGLES2 in a daydream.
The last thing I want to share with you is
you can prevent your daydream -- prevent daydreams
from running on top of your apps.
So I mentioned at the top of the talk video
players, games, kiosks things might not want
daydreams to run on top of them, and the way
you do that is you keep the screen on.
And there are lots of ways to keep the screen
on, all the way up to managing your own wake
lock which I only recommend -- for no one.
So last I want to show you a little magic
trick.
I want to give you a clock daydream in zero
lines of code.
Almost zero lines of code.
For very large values of zero.
But the only code we're going to need is the
same block of code again that we've seen over
and over in this talk.
I added a couple extra bits here.
Set full screen, set screen bright.
Those are just wrappers around basic calls
on view.
Those are put on the dream service for your
convenience.
You don't need to use them.
And then in this implementation I'm going
to set content view to my full screen clock,
and that's it.
I'm done.
So what is this clock XML, this magic clock?
Are you ready for it?
Here it is.
I'm just going to use the widget that already
exists.
So it's part of the Android widget toolkit.
It shows a clock.
It updates on its own.
I don't have to do anything.
Zero lines of code, and it works.
It looks just like that.
Hang on.
The colon needs to blink.
I know it's scope creep.
This is what happens.
I'm sure you all know.
And I said no code, so how are we going to
do it?
Any guesses?
No?
What is that?
I showed this to Romain and he face-palmed.
He said, "You're going to show those guys
that?"
So there's this little undocumented task available
in the system called blink, which makes anything
inside of it blink on and off once a second.
And it works.
No code.
So....
[ Applause ]
>>Daniel Sandler: He's going to love that
that's what got applause.
[ Laughter ]
>>Daniel Sandler: Okay.
All right.
The code is done, but I did want to show you
some more examples of other daydreams in the
wild.
First, there's Google currents, which was
-- we worked with the currents team to build
this out based on their UI, and we're really
happy with how this came out.
It was very currency, very rich, lots of great
stuff to look at.
A few things I want to draw your attention
to.
One, it's interesting and not distracting.
So it's always moving but it's always moving
slowly so there's constantly something new
to be interested in and to look at if you
happen to be looking but it's never going
to, like, draw your eye out of the corner
of the room.
It's coming direct from Currents, their fresh
database of new content so it's never stale,
and it's always interactive.
So if you tap on the story and would like
to bring up a full screen view -- again, it's
still within the daydream -- a full screen
view of that story where you can read a little
more about it, and from there you can either
go back to the river of news or you can drill
in all the way, exit daydream, and go straight
into currents.
We'll see another example of that in a minute.
It's super powerful.
(Saying name) sent me some screen shots from
some information about beautiful widgets.
I actually have been using this for a while
as my personal charging daydream on my phone.
So I go to bed, I set the phone on the wireless
charger and this comes up, which is perfect
because it tells me everything I need to know
first thing in the morning, or, you know,
at 3:00 in the morning, including the time,
the weather, things like that.
It's all live data coming directly from beautiful
widgets.
They've got these great visual effects that
would not be possible in widgets, like launcher
widgets for the weather, cloud moving past,
twinkling stars at night.
It's very future beautiful.
In fact the UI is one that wouldn't really
work with as a front door for an app.
It's much more artistic, much more free form.
It's perfect for daydream.
It feels just right in this context.
They also give you some system status information
in the bottom.
I will point out if you are interested in
that, you can also show the system you want
in what we call lights-out mode or view.systemui
flag low profile which is a way of causing
the navigation icons to dim out and your notification
stuff to dim out showing only the battery
and the clock in a lower profile way in the
corner.
So the user still has access to that battery
information and you don't have to do it yourself,
but you can if you want to.
Finally, Flipboard was kind enough to send
along a screen shot.
Flipboard always looks great, gently moving
full color photographs and stories.
And they sent this statistic that I really
wanted to share with you and they were kind
enough to let me share with you.
Nearly 50% of daydream sessions, almost half
the time that people are running Flipboard
in a daydream, ended with a launch of Flipboard
the app.
People see the daydream, see a story they're
interested in and go and read more about it.
This is a massive, massive way to drive engagement
with your app.
If you have a great daydream it is going to
drive people into your full app experience.
This is outstanding, outstanding news.
I get chills on the back of my neck thinking
about it.
It's awesome.
So let's wrap this up because I do want to
take some questions.
Daydream is supposed to be really easy for
you to write.
Very simple, similar to activity, very simple
to get off the ground.
You get lots of great stuff for free so you
don't have to think about all that stuff,
and you can use any drawing API, any UI toolkit
on Android that you like.
It's supposed to provide this delightful glanceable
information to draw the user into your app
or just to sort of look great on a bedside
table or on a coffee table or on your desk
at work.
And it's a chance for your app to have fun.
It's a chance for you to break out of the
serious business of all of your action bars
and your ListViews and more ListViews, ListViews
and more ListViews.
And finally, daydream is there for any user,
whether you have a fancy dock or a fancy charger
or just one of these, every user with Android
4.2 can use daydream.
I want to briefly thank a ton of people who
have been involved in this feature, and particularly
helping out with daydream.
In particular, Jeff, Rachel, Tom, John, and
Chris who did the implementation and the design
for this feature.
Thanks to those guys.
Flipboard and Levelup, thank you so much for
all of your feedback and thank you for your
screen shots.
Reto, the Android developer people and the
whole Google I/O team for putting on a great
show.
Thank you to those guys.
And people who had cameos, you can invoice
me later.
Dianne Matias and Baron, thank you for your
likenesses.
Questions can be asked at the microphone right
up here at the front.
If you have them, now is the time.
If you don't have questions now, immediately
after this talk I will be over in the Android
Office Hours pen elsewhere on the third floor
here.
You can ask me about daydream or anything
else related to system UI, notifications,
navigation, full screen stuff, launcher, floating
windows, things like that.
[ Applause ]
>>Daniel Sandler: Go ahead.
>>> Hi.
Is there any support for loaders for fragments
in daydream?
>>Daniel Sandler: Thank you for asking fragments
up front.
No, we haven't worked out a really good way
to integrate fragments yet because the life
cycle of fragments is so peculiar.
It was really opposed to the simplicity for
a daydream.
So a daydream had to be, like, one method
override it and you're ready to go.
Putting fragments into that hasn't worked
for us so far.
Quality patches accepted to the AOSP crowd.
>>> And loaders?
Cursive loaders?
>>Daniel Sandler: I don't know, if you have
specific problems.
We don't have any of the stuff that's in activity
to help you manage that stuff automatically
so you'll have to do it yourself.
If there are specific things you'd like to
see, again, that feedback is welcome.
>>> Thank you.
>>Daniel Sandler: Thank you.
>>> Hi.
A question about the placer.
There is a section for widgets and for wallpaper.
Is it planned to have a section for daydream?
>>Daniel Sandler: I can't comment on plans
but that's a nice idea.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> I missed the beginning so maybe you already
answered this but basically I'm wondering,
like, let's say there are more apps that have
daydream, like how do they get chosen?
The user picks which one is the dreamer or
--
>>Daniel Sandler: Let's go back over to the
tablet.
So this is actually in system settings.
So go up here, quick settings.
Oh, that's so convenient.
Go into display.
Underneath daydream, you get a choice here
of all the daydreams available on the system,
and you can select one.
You can either run it there to test it out,
or you can set it up, choose when you daydream
and things like that and then just let it
turn on automatically.
Currently there's no other way for anything
else to change which daydream you have right
now.
That's a secure setting.
That choice belongs to the user, not to the
app, but you can always direct users to this
activity.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Will daydreams running in the daydream
service, the apps running in the daydream
service have access to some of the voice recognition
and voice commands that we saw earlier today
so you can talk to your device while its in
daydream?
>>Daniel Sandler: I have no idea.
That's a great idea.
I don't know.
I'd have to check on that.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> I think I just had a follow-up on the
discovery questions that have been asked.
Do you have guidance on how developers should
encourage or make users aware that there's
a daydream feature for their app?
>>Daniel Sandler: I don't right now.
So we're still kind of working on that.
Having a different organization in Play Store
would certainly help but it's not necessary.
I think right now daydream is definitely being
driven by people who already know about the
feature and want to find apps that support
it.
In terms of somebody who already likes your
app and you want to encourage them to try
out daydream, our current sort of guidance
on this is if you already have settings, to
have a row there where you say set up daydream
and it will actually take you to this screen
right out in settings.
And there's an activity -- there's an intent
named for this particular activity that I
can dig up.
I don't have it memorized, and so you can
direct people that way.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>> Hi.
>>Daniel Sandler: Yes.
>>> One question.
So can you use the external monitor in daydream,
like can you connect to an HDMI monitor or
--
>>Daniel Sandler: Right.
So the secondary monitor API.
Yes, you can do that and then you can draw
something different there, or you can draw
the same thing.
If you don't do anything in particular, if
you're just mirroring the device you will
see the daydream in both places.
But again, you can do whatever you want.
So, yes, you should be able to run the display
API and draw something different on the HDMI
monitor if that were important.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>Daniel Sandler: Mm-hmm.
>>> Hi.
I was wondering, can you take voice input
from daydream state?
>>Daniel Sandler: I mean, yes.
Well, it was asked earlier if some of the
specific new voice recognition stuff would
be enabled, and I see no reason why not.
I honestly haven't tried a lot of those APIs
with daydream yet.
I'll check into it.
Maybe we'll have a blog post about it.
One more.
>>> I was just curious on performance issues.
Like related to battery charging, if the screen
is always on or something like that.
>>Daniel Sandler: Absolutely, yes.
>>> You leave your phone overnight charging,
so how long does it take to actually charge?
>>Daniel Sandler: It dilates the charge time.
It doesn't make it so that you can't charge
your phone overnight, and it varies based
on what's going on.
This is like dock apps; right?
So not only are you keeping the screen on,
you're keeping the CPU on.
You may be doing more or less depending on
the complexity of your animation.
That's going to be something a developer -- each
developer has to sit down and work our with
their implementation.
Somebody doing a blinking colon clock animation
is probably not going to have to worry about
it, but basically just keeping the screen
on.
That's the lion's share of the computation.
But if you have a full 3D live wallpaper,
it might be a little different.
Now daydream has some additional safeguards
in there to make sure you don't crater your
device overnight.
So if the battery gets too low daydream will
shut off and the screen will go dark and the
device will be allowed to charge fully.
And daydream won't automatically start if
you put the device into a dock if the charge
is too low.
So in that way we won't ever -- daydream won't
cause your device to wake up with zero charge
but it will cause charging to take longer
and that's -- just like any performance issue,
each developer is going to have to sit down
and look at that.
>>>Is there any consideration to make -- to
sort of link daydream with your alarm set
time?
So say as you're close to waking up, the app
that you're using to daydream could change
its actions when it knows you're about to
wake up.
>>Daniel Sandler: That's a great idea.
Go monetize that.
Thank you all very much.
I'll see you all outside.
[ Applause ]